muchos pensaron que la Cumbre de altos
cargos de defensa en la base aérea de
Rammstein en Alemania supondría un punto
de inflexión en el apoyo militar de
occidente a Ucrania pero finalmente las
esperanzas se desvanecieron ya que los
aliados no llegaron a un consenso sobre
el envío de los tanques alemanes
leopardos las fuerzas de kiev están
desesperadas por tener en sus manos este
armamento pesado antes de una esperada
nueva ofensiva rusa Berlín receloso de
una escalada bélica se muestra reticente
esto ha provocado una oleada de críticas
a Alemania por no hacer lo suficiente
Para apoyar a kiev acusaciones que
Berlín niega
la impresión que a veces se tiene de que
existe una coalición unida y que
Alemania se impone en su camino es falsa
hay muchos aliados que dicen compartir
la opinión que una vez más expuse aquí
hoy
el Secretario de Defensa estadounidense
apoyó públicamente a Alemania este
viernes saben Alemania ha contribuido
mucho a esto a esta campaña son un
Aliado fiable en su discurso diario
nocturno
presidente ucraniano volvió a presionar
Alemania para que diera luz verde a la
entrega de los tanques
Sí todavía Tendremos que luchar por el
suministro de tanques modernos pero cada
día hacemos más evidente que no hay
alternativa que tomar una decisión sobre
los tanques
ya puede que los leopardos no lleguen a
Ucrania pero los aliados occidentales
están aumentando su apoyo con Estados
Unidos prometiendo equipos militares por
valor de 2.500 millones de dólares
mientras que los países europeos como
Reino Unido o Polonia han prometido
enviar nuevos paquetes de defensa pero
el kremlin insiste en que el apoyo
adicional no cambiará el curso de la
guerra